[Music]  will you renfield take this woman baba  yaga  hi what is it you are wanting at our  wedding  you  what is that girl doing here she's some  sort of monster hunter  your new targets are messy the loch ness  monster and yeti  the snow monster of the himalayas we  have to stop her max no prepare me for  the fight mom he's gonna turn us all  into monsters again on this magical  monster night  oh great job max but how can we save  them if we don't know where they are i  can find anyone with this party people  disappear pronto  [Music]  that doesn't work on me i am perfect  [Music]  [Applause]  oh  [Music]  you are all crazy  okay that's not good  prince  [Music]  bye